schwerer verdacht gegen ex fußball
nationalspieler christoph metzelder die
staatsanwaltschaft hamburg ermittelt
gegen ihn wegen des verdachts der
verbreitung von kinderpornografie die
polizei hatte einen hinweis bekommen
dass eine frau über whatsapp
entsprechendes material von metzelder
erhalten haben soll
der 38 jährige hat sich bisher nicht zu
den vorwürfen geäußert david sauer
berichtet er war an dieser sportschule
zum trainerlehrgang als die
staatsanwaltschaft christoph metzelder
mit dem schwerwiegenden verdacht
konfrontiert
damit schafft hamburg für hat ein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen einen
beschuldigten christoph metzelder wegen
des verdachts der verbreitung
kinderpornografischer schriften es geht
um bilder die sexuelle handlungen an und
von kindern zeigen diese soll er einer
frau über whatsapp geschickt haben noch
an der sportschule wurde sein handy
sichergestellt
anschließend seine düsseldorfer wohnung
durchsucht datenträger sichergestellt
metzelder hat mit den ermittlern
kooperiert sich bislang aber weder
gegenüber der staatsanwaltschaft noch
auf anfrage des zdf geäußert
der 38 jährige spielte bei dortmund real
madrid und schalke wurde deutscher
meister dfb-pokalsieger vize-weltmeister
wurde sogar als dfb-präsident gehandelt
er engagiert sich für soziale zwecke
auch für initiativen zum kinderschutz
seit sommer ist metzelder fußball
experte der ard
die lässt die zusammenarbeit bis zur
klärung der vorwürfe ruhen
christoph metzelder muss aufgrund des
öffentlich gemachten
ermittlungsverfahrens bereits jetzt mit
schweren konsequenzen leben
dabei verbietet sich zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt jede vorverurteilung es gilt
die unschuldsvermutung
zwar gibt es belastbare hinweise aber
auch jede menge offene fragen etwa warum
metzelder diese bilder über whatsapp an
eine freundin versendet haben sollte die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt
weiter wertet die sichergestellten
beweismittel aus ergebnisse sind noch
nicht bekannt